you're asking for a 1% of 1% life so far
I've heard I didn't want to eat [ __ ] and
put out stuff and deal with no feedback
for a year or two I don't want to spend
the three or four hours to like learn it
cuz it seems like there's so much you
have to realize when you're asking to do
to live a 1% life that you need to do 1%
things you got your perspective
[Music]
yes what's up my brother it's a real
pleasure
such a pleasure I appreciate that
yeah I mean I appreciate that I
appreciate that it's a real pleasure to
see you we were just talking for a
second and you know I mean like him
being like let's go how did it start
coming champagne right place at the
right time always of course I really
want to get because you there's a lot of
you that I see that reminds you of
myself which is all this yeah because
that means you spread to so many
different ways so I'm [ __ ] you real
all that [ __ ] back in and then make you
make your work the reason I think I've
been able to pull it off is 60 to 80
percent always go to one core big thing
and then I get my nut off on all my
other stuff but I got one thing that's
like you know like it's like a piece of
it's like food like there's always a
steak or a chicken but I got a fuckload
of Brussels sprouts and carrots and say
you know but there's always a core and
it's and that was either to wine store
in Springfield Jersey or vaynermedia if
we could figure out on Instagram or
Facebook or snaps snap you know there's
places like for me it's running ads on
the internet in lower income individuals
targeting lower income individuals who
are more likely to not have a plan in
that sweet kind of like 20 to 30 spot
because if you're younger a lot of times
your parents are doing it you hit them
hard with a bunch of different messages
like hey don't worry about you know
getting a you know a plan we can go
month-to-month like you catch the right
video the right you know it's just like
a commercial like on TV
like there's millions of commercials but
just do it or priceless or where's the
beef you know like that's the goal of my
company always like what's the Internet
good cool we have two five seven eight
years is that what I'm facing really is
that just like yeah it's like three five
videos constantly constantly eventually
to like you're just you just care about
short-term feedback loops well a couple
things you can do you can spend money
against the content right so then you
can just be patient and wait for it to
come and when I say you can spend money
and maybe you don't have this either but
you're here so this will you should have
this I think spending 200 bucks against
a video highly targeted will get you
feedback yep I think the thing that you
have to wrap your head around is what
you're asking for think about this
you said I what you know it's really
important I think you're gonna know what
I'm gonna go I want to live a life where
I can travel three to four months a year
and still run my business and make money
like you're asking for a 1% of 1% life
you're looking to build a personal brand
so that you can travel for months a year
yes you have to realize when you're
asking to do to live a 1% life that you
need to do 1% things
so far I've heard I didn't want to eat
[ __ ] and put out stuff and deal with no
feedback for a year or two because it
doesn't feel like it's accomplishing
anything that makes sense to me yeah
yeah I don't want to spend the three or
four hours to like learn it cuz it seems
like there's so much yeah man
stick with me here though you want to
live a one-percent life like you have to
do 1% things like that's super hard to
live a life where you get to travel for
months a year like that was outrageous
of what you just asked for it
no but think about it but it says this
is everything this is the whole nut that
you have the reason you haven't figured
you're [ __ ] out of your mind with
what you're asking thus you have to do
ridiculously hard [ __ ] to get there and
you're not even giving it a chain or
dump you're bailing on the hard [ __ ]
within seconds like every data point
that I've heard so far it's okay it's
like no chance let alone some chance
because I don't think you've want to
bite how ridiculous what you're asking
for is which is yes yes Steve Steve
Steve
you all said three [ __ ] heart attacks
and that's an end to your point how many
years did it take us when did we do it
years dude I [ __ ] worked in a liquor
store for 15 hours a day seven days a
week for years and somehow people put
that as like part of my narrative but
don't give it the respect you want to
live a one-percent life cool so then you
wanted to build you told me you wanted
to build it you thought that building a
personal brand is the way to do that
the two core things in building a print
which is fine the two core things in a
personal brand you've bailed on
immediately patience and practitioner
ship you don't want to do either I know
that you're gonna want to take some
photos I need to like this okay cool
thank you I'll see you guys later thank
you guys thank you so much
you we're late so one thing we want to
do what size t-shirt are you I'm gonna
grab your medium
grab your medium semi unaware that I'm
gonna wear I'm gonna give you that we
once wanted to take group before we
start the programming one quick picture
with the whole board
[Music]
oh well everything's
[Music]
well here it raised by us charity about
an organization that helps organizations
in their employees give back really
enjoying it on the board super happy
about it here with this beautiful man
bed layer famous now yes Emily and Ellie
in the corner thank you so now we're
gonna do so we're going to do this much
more quickly than most panels but we
felt like because we had such an
esteemed group of interesting and
wonderful board members it would be
disrespectful not to let me share their
immense knowledge in particular Jeremy
Darren is you so vaynermedia's they've
been in hyper growth firing huge numbers
people for four years now are you what's
the thing that you struggle most with
from a cultural perspective as you as
you sort of know the team fast
sure so I think there's a lot of
variables and I'll use the context of
the other answers in here you know this
ecosystem a lot of faces I see I think
what was interesting is when I started
Boehner I was coming from investing and
and kind of the tech ecosystem and with
Vayner it's how to be profitable we
didn't raise capital so it's one thing
to maintain culture when you can get
away with losing money every year it's
another thing when you have to make
payroll every two weeks so for me
I agree with everything here and on top
of it I have to be profitable every day
since we've had it that's number one
number two I didn't come from the
advertising world and so my biggest
problem is for the nine hundred people
that work for me I'm a little bit of an
enigma and a lot of my actions because
I'm also breaking the industry and
having different perspectives on
creative and media so the truth is up
you know every day in the process of
what we're doing we're I'm fighting a
market that doesn't necessarily want to
buy what I'm selling employees that are
holding up the past on a pedestal so
then everything's a problem
does the New York tech community have an
obligation or responsibility to give
back and and why do you think that's the
case
and what if he does have to answer
I mean the answer is yes because it'd be
if to me it's not about the New York
tech community it's about every human
and organization on earth if you have
the there's an unbelievable
misunderstanding of how much abundance
there is in the world and I think if
you're lucky enough to be in a position
to be able to whether you're a human
individual here or an organization a
start-up the New York tech community the
San Francisco tech community the Tokyo
tech community the fashion community in
Germany whatever you are I think there's
there's a real deep need to understand
that there's an underlining obligation
if you've been gifted enough with the
proper DNA and circumstance that
something good is going on then I just
want to add one thing in the way that
you ask the question of like how do you
think about the ROI of social purpose
it's really interesting for me I don't
think about it at all I think one of the
things I'm fascinated by is when you're
giving that should be it the the thought
that there's so many people that are
using doing the right thing as a gateway
drug to a financial output I think has
caused a lot of cynicism and a lot of
things that I've seen in startups that
make me upset not happy because I've
seen they front-loaded the profits to
make it look like they're trying to do
good when they're just trying to make
money like when I give I give
period move on and so I think that's an
interesting conversation that I don't
see touched on and I think that's
something that should be debated a
little bit I think to that point of that
interaction I think in these scenarios
and I think some of us said that the
luxury of being involved in boards or
being at these kind of events like when
I think about my life so many times I've
been in the audience have been at things
compelled by emotional stories or things
that I could help with and then the high
of the moment goes away the next day
comes life takes over and you know act
and so I think for us you know for me
whether it's the silent auction or if
you're in a position where it's not
financial and you can volunteer I think
what I'm doing here to wrap it up is
like here's my action above and beyond
and I would it would mean the world to
all of us associated whether through
some hustle as a volunteer bidding on
something at the silent auction table
that
can go flip on eBay later or however you
roll or by making a donation or getting
your organization involved it would mean
so much to us if you could take action
on today it you know and and that's
that's how I see it so thank you so much
for being here
[Music]